[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the new report of the larry nassar case
saying the fbi
botched their investigation allowing for
more than 70 young women and girls to be
abused
the gymnast now demanding action we know
that what happened
was extremely corrupt britney spears
wins her bid
to choose her own attorney that is what
i think a lot of
fans actually in particular wanted was
somebody in her
corner the pop star calling for an
investigation into her father
for conservatorship abuse will the tiger
king regain his throne
his sentence on federal charges now
tossed out shocking claims by the
defense of an iowa farm worker
convicted of murdering college student
molly tibbetts should a new trial be
granted
there's something rotten in this area
plus
a jury now deliberating the fate of mark
redwine we break down closing arguments
in the trial of the colorado father
accused of murdering his son
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
britney spears claims a big victory in
court as the judge in her
conservatorship
allows her to hire her own lawyer law
and crimes anjanet levy is here with the
latest allegations by the pop icon
anjanet brian this is really something
that britney spears wanted she wanted to
hire a lawyer of her own choosing
her mother lynn supported her in this
and so did the conservator
of her person jody montgomery and
spears's new lawyer actually
called on her father to resign from the
conservatorship
for months britney spears's fans have
flocked to the courthouse to support the
free brittany movement
this time a victory as the judge said
spears could hire celebrity attorney
matthew rosengart
to replace her court appointed lawyer
who resigned
her new lawyer one of the first things
he did was say you know i think
mr spears should resign you know on his
own and mr spears has already come out
or his lawyers already come out and said
that's not going to happen
britney spears spoke through tears at
the latest hearing
saying she wants her dad jamie
investigated for conservatorship abuse
and that she is quote extremely scared
of him calling the arrangement
effing cruelty jamie spears's lawyer
telling the judge that spears made a
number of misstatements to the court
last month
and said there's no reason for jamie
spears to step down
britney spears new lawyer saying they
will seek to end the conservatorship
so if she does indeed file a petition to
terminate
i think it's very likely that mr spears
will or his lawyers
will you know object to that which would
result in a trial
she actually has a right to a trial even
by a jury
after the hearing britney spears posted
a video on instagram she was doing
cartwheels and riding a horse
she thanked her fans for supporting her
writing coming along
folks new with real representation today
using the hashtag free britney for the
first time
now i reached out to the ventura county
sheriff's office
the new yorker actually reported that
the sheriff's office went to britney
spears's home the night before the last
hearing back in june because she had
called to report
conservatorship abuse the vegetarian
county sheriff's office confirmed to me
that they did go
to britney spears's home that night but
they did not release that 9-1-1 call so
we haven't been able to hear that just
yet
brian thanks angenet back with us his
co-host terry austin
terry after britney spears his phone
call into court
many in her camp jump ship what do you
think could be the reason for that
i think most of the people in her camp
realize that she wants to be on her own
the manager recognized the fact that
she's going to retire soon
and i think the attorney recognizes the
fact that
she wants someone who can advocate
versus someone who
is court appointed so i think that the
new attorney is going to move forward
and is going to get everyone off her
back
and get her to be able to make her own
decisions because she's
absolutely competent all right so
angeannette now that
britney spears has her own attorney that
she's selected
what's the next step for her and this
new attorney well he said outside of the
court yesterday that they still have to
iron out some of the details of his
representation of her but he's going to
represent her and he's going to seek
uh to get he's going to try to get you
know up to speed on the entire case
which he has to do in a short amount of
time because this is
going on for so long and then he plans
to file to end the conservatorship so we
just need to wait to see
how long that whole process will take
and of course we'll keep eyes on that
because once they
file they'll have a plethora a whole
bunch
of allegations that they're trying to
support to get bernie spears out of this
conservatorship and we'll make sure to
have that
for you next time and now to a scathing
report released in the larry nassar case
the office of the inspector general now
saying the fbi's failure to act
allowed some 70 young gymnasts to be
sexually assaulted
the federal investigation finding the
fbi delayed ramping up his investigation
by more than a year while nassar abused
more women and girls
according to the 119 page report the
indianapolis field office special agent
and another unidentified agent neglected
to interview accusers
limited follow-up and lie to officials
to minimize errors
it is about time it is about time we've
been asking for that for so
long sarah klein is believed to be
nassar's first victim
she's now an attorney and helped guide
hundreds of young athletes
as they face their accuser as you
massaged the entirety of my 12 year old
body
suggesting that i relax as you slipped
your adult fingers in and
out and in and out
of my body nassar is serving a 40-174
year sentence
this defendant has been brought to
justice
i just find your death warrant
terry this report is not shy about
pointing out the shortcomings
of this investigation what are some of
the bigger flaws in this investigation
that you saw
well the inspector general report was
scathing and i think some of the biggest
flaws was the failure to investigate
and even the small amount of
investigation that they did
they did not document and i think
worse than all of that is they didn't
report it to
local authorities and they lied about
that brian so
i think that the report rightly points
out that there was failure all around as
far as these
local fbi individuals are concerned
absolutely a lot of
allegations and accusations but is there
a remedy to any of this
i mean criminal charges civil charges
maybe some people don't work at the fbi
anymore
what can these women do absolutely there
should be civil charges because at any
point in time
any of these women can sue for
intentional infliction
of emotional distress all you have to
show is some
documentation that you had some
emotional distress
and they can certainly prove that and
that it was either reckless
or intentional and the other thing brian
is i think the individuals and the
report pointed this
out the inspectors who were there and
they were
not actually investigating and lying
about it i think that they should be
fired for cause the special agent and
his deputy
both should be fired for cause there's
plenty of action there as far as that's
concerned
so potentially change of personnel as
well as potential civil charges we'll
keep our eyes on that
as that continues after that scathing
119 page report
thank you terry still ahead on law and
crime daily the length friends of robert
durst are apparently willing to go
to cover his tracks but first the man
convicted of murdering college student
molly tibbetts is back in court
why his defense wants a new trial next
welcome back an iowa farm worker
convicted of killing college student
molly tibbetts
wants a new trial he claims another man
confessed to the murder
christian bahina rivera's attorney asked
for a new trial after an inmate came
forward claiming another inmate
confessed that he killed tibbetts after
seeing her bound and gagged in a sex
trafficker's home
an ex-girlfriend of the inmate reported
the same confession to police
the same day the defense found out about
the inmates claims during the trial from
the prosecutors
but prosecutors say the defense refused
an offer to halt the trial so the claim
could be investigated
the defense now wants to connect
tibbetts murder to an alleged sex
trafficker and the disappearance of an
11 year old boy
we have information that three people
have vanished out of thin air in
this small rural county
molly tibbetts xavier harrelson
and the woman that reported being
abducted
in may of 2018 and sex trafficked
prosecutors say the evidence used to
convict the defendant is overwhelming
and that they have no obligation to turn
over new information
post trial we provided them
enough detail that they knew because mr
freeze told me
in front of witnesses that what we were
telling them was
inconsistent with what his client
testified to
we told them about the secondary
location that she would had been tied up
uh that another person that was involved
mr freeze told me in front of witnesses
that it was completely inconsistent with
what his client testified to
and that's why we proceeded they've got
buyer's remorse when it comes to this
information
we offered to stop the trial to go to
you and ask to stop the trial
to pursue the information that mr mackey
was providing to us
they declined i left it 100 percent up
to them
the defense fired back saying even more
new information was discovered
after the verdict and that they did not
receive the report of the attempted
abduction
of another woman months before molly
tibbetts was killed
you bet your pants we would have said
stop
wheels we need you run this down now
they don't want to run it down
after offering it earlier now they don't
have to they don't want to
there's evidence here that 10 kids
in this area have gone missing we've
we've provided that
there's something rotten in this area
back with us is terry austin and
antoinette levy terry the fact
there may be an alternative suspect is
huge but how is the defense arguing this
fact in front of the judge
i actually think the defense did a very
good job arguing it in front of the
judge this team chad and jennifer
freezey the defense team
they took turns arguing and jennifer
dufrese
actually just said that there's this new
evidence
where arnie mackey claims that gavin
jones another inmate
told him that he killed molly tibbetts
and then jennifer freeze
explains the defense attorney explains
that this is corroborated by lindy voss
who is apparently the ex-girlfriend of
gavin jones and that gavin jones told
her that he also
killed molly tibbett so i think there's
enough here
i do think that if i were the judge here
i would want to err on the side of
caution
and this new evidence really should be
heard just to make a determination that
you have the right person behind bars
absolutely you never want to get it
wrong in that type of situation
and jeanette the prosecution is pushing
back on a number of fronts
timing of the disclosure the defendants
in action when they were first told
do you think this verdict will be final
based on what you've heard so far
you know i think it's really hard to
tell i think that what we've seen is
we've seen some arguments in court we've
seen some things on paper
there will be a hearing on this a
day-long hearing likely later this month
in which that inmate who said that the
other inmate confessed to him will be
brought in
and put on the stand and we will hear
from him that gives more time for the
prosecution to look into this but right
now they are saying look we got our guy
none of this fits so it'll be
interesting to see how it all plays out
absolutely the facts are the facts
digging in to them to see whether or not
christian benejo rivera is the actual
person who killed molly tibbetts i'm
assuming must take precedent over
everything else
so we'll see how this continues and
we'll make sure to give you updates
here along crime daily thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily
disturbing writings found in the diary
of a teen accused of murdering his
classmate
plus a big ruling for a big cat lover
the tiger king's winning appeal argument
and what it means for when he'll get out
of prison next
[Music]
we're back the tiger king is set to get
out of prison just a little bit earlier
a federal appeals court has ordered a
shorter sentence for joe exotic
exotic was sentenced to 22 years in
prison for a murder for a higher plot of
carol baskin
but on appeal a three-judge panel has
now ruled the trial court
aired and he should have been sentenced
to between 17
and a half years and just under 22 years
the trial court will now have to
resentence exotic
he's being represented by attorney john
phillips who released this statement
from the tiger king himself
the witnesses that all want to come
forward and have came forward
i'd like to thank them for finally
having a
clean conscience to come forward and
admit
everything what they have already
admitted to perjury
and what the government made them do to
put me here
all through the name of the catholic
because carol baskin made it very well
known that she would help me get out of
here if i
support her bill now to florida where
new documents show a teen
charged with murder made a stunning
claim when confronted about the death of
a 13 year old girl
tristan bailey was found stabbed to
death with 114
wounds in may her 14 year old classmate
aiden fauci
is being charged as an adult with
first-degree murder investigators now
say they found a notebook in his room
with satanic symbols and violent
drawings according to court records fuji
changed his story later telling
detectives he was walking with bayley
that she tried to grab him and he pushed
her to the ground
causing her to hit her head he's plead
not guilty
and in california a friend of real
estate heir robert durst
is being called to testify against him
susan guardano is accused of helping
durst
flee before the final episode of the hbo
series the jinx aired
durst was arrested in new orleans in
2015 he's on trial
for the murder of his best friend susan
berman in court durst has been seen
waving at giordano
and fist-pumping her as she left the
stand prosecutors say durst has given
her 350 thousand dollars and promised to
make sure
she's set for life be sure to tune in to
law and crime network for capital gavel
coverage
when we come back closing arguments in
the mark redwine trial
which side will the jury believe inside
the colorado courtroom
after the break
[Music]
welcome back a jury is now deliberating
the fate of a colorado man
accused of murdering his 13 year old son
mark redwine stands trial for the death
of dylan redwine the teen vanished on
thanksgiving weekend in 2012
while on a court mandated trip to his
father's redwine maintains his innocence
claiming that wild animals could have
killed the boy after he ran away
in their closing arguments prosecutors
say redwine killed dylan in a fit of
rage
the boy allegedly confronted him after
seeing photos of his father
dressed in women's lingerie and eating
feces
you heard dr kirkman talk about how
there's a fracture to one's face
that could cause a radiating fracture up
into the head
if someone is slammed into something
forcefully like a coffee table
or something is slammed against their
head forcefully
and it's called homicide and then the
cuffs the defense expert
eric smith told you these cuts seem to
him in his expert opinion to be the
result of slicing
cutting action this defendant is guilty
ladies and gentlemen
he is guilty of murder in the second
degree and child abuse resulting in
death
he was the last person seen with dylan
when dylan goes
completely dark and has never heard from
again
he's in the living room with this guy
he's angry and upset
and rageful dylan's blood is in his
living room
he has the smell of a dead body in the
same room
on his clothes and in his truck
and he has dylan's debit card
his changing stories and behavior are
incredibly suspicious and evasive
until you realize it's completely
consistent with a murderer
the defense disagrees and says this case
has a lack of evidence
asking the jury to find mark redwine not
guilty
after nine years five weeks of trial all
this investigation
they can't tell you what happened
he said can you imagine can you imagine
if this happened can you imagine if that
happened can you imagine if he said
f u can you imagine can you imagine if
he said hey
shit eater can you imagine that or what
if this happened
what if this happened maybe this
happened
when someone's on trial for murdering
their youngest sons
and the prosecutions thesis
is what if or may be or can you imagine
that's a window into how weak
the evidence is in this case
when the thesis of the government is can
you imagine
what if maybe this happened
when they're starting off with maybe
your deliberations end with not guilty
changing stories potentially a strong
argument by the prosecution
did you think the defense had anything
to raise reasonable doubt here in this
consciousness
of guilt argument you know
i'm not so sure about that i mean he his
behavior
was just not that of somebody whose
child is missing
on his watch i've said this many times
before you know dylan
was a 13 year old boy he's still a kid
and he goes to see his dad for the first
time in a while there's hanging out and
then he goes missing and the kid is
nowhere to be found so there
there is a lot of stuff that you can tie
together circumstantially that does not
make mark redwine look very good
i think one of the strongest things is
that we still don't know exactly how
dylan died they said there was blunt
force trauma to the skull
but but we don't know exactly for sure
what happened
yeah that was a big point by the defense
terry the what-ifs
as we saw there uh lack of evidence uh
may not be the winning argument here
what evidence is being tied
to use uh red to tie red wine sorry to
this murder
and did you think it was lacking or did
you think it was strong
i actually thought the prosecution did a
great job i thought the evidence was
very strong first of all the dna
evidence that blood dna
that was found on the corner of the
table on the couch in the house
under the rug i mean that says something
right there that tells me that there was
something going on that it was violent
and i think also
this fact that dylan was last with
his father that was the last person to
see him in his custody
and his care and he obviously owed a
duty of care to his son he's only 13
years old
as angenette mentioned and i also think
that
because dylan and mark did not have a
positive relationship that that shows
there might have been some
motive behind and there's no question i
was reading
some comments by some of our viewers
that that
debit card the fact that the father had
the debit card
that is something that says why are you
trying to make
access to these funds you wouldn't be
doing that if your child was missing
and he didn't really help with the
search so
i think all of that put together makes a
very strong case
against mark and i think the prosecution
has done enough to get a verdict here
but terry just being devil's advocate
everything you said there was all
circumstantial that did not answer the
question as to murder so how's that
going to play out
that's true brian and all you need is
one person and there might be
just enough doubt we'll see how that
plays out thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you